the younger generation decides to
lecture their parents on racism Shaun
King announces it's time to start
tearing down stained glass windows of
white Jesus and president Trump
struggles as Cova 19 researches is the
this is the Ben Shapiro show today's
show is sponsored by expressvpn protect
your data from prying eyes at expressvpn
dot-com / Ben well we're gonna get to
all of the news and there is plenty of
it there was an attempt to take over
Lafayette Park again st. John's Church
got two-faced again there's an attempt
to create a black house autonomous zone
is what they were trying to call it it
failed so we'll get to all of that plus
all of the latest news on covin 19 as
there is a resurgence around the country
but first you know it can be pretty
refreshing to finally pay off those
credit cards a lot of people take out
credit card debt and then it takes them
forever to pay off the credit cards or
they never do because the net starts to
rack up as soon as you start racking up
those interest rate charges it is very
hard to put that genie back in the
bottle well if you're having trouble
doing that you really need to talk to my
friends over at lights trim you can get
a credit card consolidation loan from a
light stream and save thousands in
interest get a rate as low as 5.95 APR
with Auto pay and excellent credit lower
than average credit card interest rates
over 19%
APR the rate is fixed so we'll never go
up over the life of the loan plus there
are absolutely no fees you can even get
your money in the bank account as soon
as the day you apply people love lights
trim because obviously it's helping them
save a lot of money is helping them get
their finances back in order
one customer says I heard about light
scream while listening to one of my
favorite podcasts it's this one but it
prompted me to do some more research
after shopping around for a personal
loan that would help me get a lower
interest rate there was no one easier to
work with plus light stream had the best
rate by far so go get a rate right now
from light stream applied today to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get the
discount is to go to light stream comm
slash Shapiro that is Li ght stre am
calm slash Shapiro subject accredited
approval rate includes 0.50% auto pay
discount terms and conditions apply
offers are subject to change without
notice
visit light stream comm slash ship hero
for more information and consolidate
that credit card loan and get that
particular issue off of your off of your
list alrighty so and there's been a lot
of talk about the continuation of racism
in America and the
that America is systemically racist
filled with racists all of our systems
are racist and I'm wondering exactly
what the evidence is of this that there
is widespread American racism
particularly widespread white American
racism against black Americans by polls
the United States is one of the least
racist countries on planet Earth by
polling data okay bye-bye
actual by actual violent crime data the
United States has very very little info
racial crime white on black right that
does not happen very often the evidence
that there's widespread American racism
that white Americans are looking to do
bad things to black people on a regular
basis or that they are attempting to
shift their institutions so as to harm
black people the evidence of that is
incredibly incredibly scanty when we see
it
we call it out right when we see bad
situations we call it out see this is
the thing that is so puzzling about our
entire moment is there seems to be a
widespread perception that America is
broadly speaking racist its systems are
broadly speaking racist and yet people
are having trouble identifying which
systems are racist and which people are
racist and the reason people are having
trouble identifying that is anytime
there is a racist incident there's an
extraordinary outpouring of support for
the person who is victimized by the
alleged racist racist incident so a
perfect example happened this week
there's a huge story out of NASCAR so
there's a driver a black fryer named
Bubba Wallace and Bubba Wallace had
called for it ends the Confederate flag
in NASCAR and he wanted to put black
lives matter on his car so you put black
lives matter on his cars my
understanding and then NASCAR went along
with his request right there are a lot
of people who fly the Confederate flag
not because they are racist but because
they believe that it it represents other
in heritage we've discussed the morphing
meaning of the flag and the differential
meanings of the flag for various
different groups in American public life
all of which I think are completely
legitimate as I've said before I think
the black people look at the Confederate
flag and they say hey that's the flag
that flew for people who wanted to
enslave my great great grandfather I get
it I really do that makes perfect sense
to me I also know a lot of southerners
who fly the Confederate flag not because
they back racism or slavery but because
that was a flag that their grandfather
flew in the Battle of the Bulge and so
they see it as a southern pride thing I
get that too I see how two people could
look at the same symbol one could find a
deeply offensive and be correct and one
could find it deeply non offensive and
also be correct from their perspective
right there are differences of
perspective here when it comes to the
Confederate flag it's sort of like
Rashomon and it really does depend
on your subjective perspective on the
issue but if you are a sports league
like NASCAR your private industry and
you want to take down the Confederate
flag totally within your rights to do so
so NASCAR goes along with this and then
yesterday or day before a story emerges
from NASCAR that apparently a noose was
found in the garage stall of Bubba
Wallace is Richard Petty Motorsports
team before the postponed Cup race at
Talladega Superspeedway a little bit
earlier this week and so that was a huge
story because black driver who has been
instrumental in trying to push NASCAR to
get rid of the confederate flag and then
he finds a noose in his locker now we
don't know all the circumstances yet we
don't know who did this yet right NASCAR
is investigating presumably they will
find out I mean NASCAR's garages I
promise you there are cameras in there
the FBI is also investigating so we
should find out sooner rather than later
and whoever did that should obviously be
punished and everyone agrees on this
that that is a great example of a racist
incident right depending on who did it
that is a great I mean it's hard to
think of it not being a racist incident
obviously so NASCAR puts out a statement
says we are angry and outraged and
cannot state strongly enough how
seriously we take this heinous act we've
launched an immediate investigation
we'll do everything we can to identify
the person responsible and eliminate
them from the sport as we have stated
unequivocally there's no place for
racism in NASCAR this act only
strengthens our resolve to make the
sport open and welcoming to all the FBI
and the DOJ Civil Rights Division are
reviewing the situation surrounding the
news that was found in bubble Wallace's
garage to determine whether there are
violations of federal law regardless of
whether federal charges can be brought
this type of action has no place in our
society says US Attorney Jo who is the
US District Attorney for the Northern
District of Alabama and so in other
words a bad thing happens and the
reaction is overwhelming in support of
the black driver overwhelming in the
images that came out of Talladega
yesterday are stunning it is the image
of everyone who works at Talladega
pushing Bubba Watson's car to the Bubble
Wallace's car rather to the front of the
of the Speedway right there is a March
where all the drivers got out like all
of them and all of their pit workers and
they pushed his car all the way to the
front of the track right into the to the
post position on the front of the track
which is I would think an amazing
display of hating racism and I think
that that signifies where virtually
every American is when it comes to
racism every American of a good heart
now he said that's nice
9% of Americans 98% of Americans
despises racism and thinks racism is
really bad you can see that in action
right here all of Nascars drivers have
rallied around Bubba Wallace the NASCAR
Cup Series lone black driver after what
happened here yesterday afternoon the
drivers led by reigning Cup Series
champion Kyle Busch and green and their
crews the entire garage area has rallied
around Bubba Wallace and the number 43
today okay so can we stop pretending
that this is like some Alabama you know
in in someone Mississippi in 1962 can we
stop pretending that that is that that's
what this is because it isn't I mean you
have literally an entire
an entire group of people and I mean
like every Americans dedicated to wiping
away the scourge of races in Selma
Alabama rather I was right the first
time the the idea here being that that
somehow America is deeply racist when
you have every NASCAR driver
walking Bubba Wallace to the front of
the track here in support of him after a
noose was found in his locker and after
NASCAR the sport backed him and got rid
of the confederate flag which again is
important to many of the people who
watch the sport this doesn't seem like a
very racist country to me I'll be honest
with you that does not seem like the
hallmark of a racist country is not
something that you saw in apartheid
South Africa this is not something that
you saw in the Jim Crow South like this
is it's utterly unthinkable I would
imagine that if you are a black person
who lived through the Jim Crow South the
very sight of Bubba Wallace's car in
Talladega being walked to the front of
the track by a bunch of white drivers
right because he's the only black driver
in NASCAR and NASCAR taking his advice
in getting rid of the confederate flag
that's pretty good evidence that there
is a lot of support for the notion that
racism is bad right these are these are
unifying sentiments that racism is bad
and yet the idea is that we have to
continue to maintain that black
Americans are at constant threat of
extinction like these are that America
is an extinction level event for black
Americans it's just not true it's just
not true
the overwhelming sentiment of Americans
and by the way tolerance for extreme
behavior by people who are protesting
what they believe to be racism is fairly
good evidence that America is on board
America is not in favor of racism and
yet the narrative
being told that America is continuing to
be in favor of racism and the quest
never ends right the quest never ends
it's perpetual revolution because not
enough to do what they did over at
Talladega we'll get to more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that social media companies are
now deciding what content is suitable
for you and for the sensitive snowflakes
among us they are targeting your data
they're monetizing your data and they're
controlling what data you can see well
there's one thing you can control their
access to your data and that is why I
use Express at VPN see the problem with
big tech companies is that not only do
they censor what you read they will
actually track what you do online they
track what you're searching for the
videos you watch everything you click
they use that data to serve you ads and
then they can match your activity to
your offline identity using your
device's unique IP address now when I
use Express with VPN these tech
companies cannot see my IP address at
all my identity is masked and anonymous
by secure VPN server plus expressvpn
also encrypts 100% of your data to
protect you from hackers and internet
bad guys
does that sound complicated it isn't it
is not right Express VPN software it is
very easy to install it takes just one
click and you're ready to go and then
you are protected I mean it's super
simple it runs in the background your
computer won't slow down your internet
which is obviously a priority for me
it's time to take back your privacy
today at expressvpn com slash been visit
my special link you'll get next for
three months of Express VPN service for
free who doesn't like to save money
right again that's expr ESS VPN comm
slash been express it VPN dot-com slash
been for more in formation alrighty so
as I say it seems to me the evidence is
pretty strong that Americans despise
racism and Americans of all stripes
think racism is really really bad in
fact Americans hate racism so much that
they are not willing to talk about
instances of a parrot racism where the
races are not the ones that fit the
narrative so for example there was this
attack that I talked about yesterday on
the show it was filmed and went viral
online in which a black man beat the
living hell out of a white Macy's
employee and then claimed that he used
the n-word
there's a really bad incident really bad
incidents okay and the only people who
are talking about it of course people on
conservative radio and people on the
conservative world are talking about
this because they're making the point
that you know it's quite fascinating the
disparate attention that is paid to acts
of racism in the United States if this
were a white guy walking into a Macy's
and beating the hell out of a black
employee
that would lead the news every night for
weeks and the reason for that is because
again the media narrative is that racism
only exists when it comes to white on
black racism there's no such thing as
black on white racism also there's this
idea from the media that if you pay
attention to attacks like this one that
it leads to bad narratives at least have
bad nerves in which people might become
racist about black people by seeing this
sort of incident now I think most people
are smart enough to look at this sort of
incident and not attribute this to black
people at large I think most people are
smart enough to look at an incident like
this to say hey that's a bad person
who's doing a racist thing it appears
but that that the same way that the Left
refuses to is it here's the thing for
the left it's a lot of projection the
left sees a white person to a bad thing
to a black person and immediately
attributes that to American Society writ
large and white people writ large and so
they assume that if Americans were to
see a black person do a bad thing to a
white person that all of America would
then suggest that all black people are
responsible for this the only people who
talk in terms of collective
responsibility for actions on a racial
level are people on the left and that is
why they don't want to talk about
incidents like that because with leftist
logic then collective action collective
responsibility starts to take home but
for regular people they look at
incidents of racism they say okay people
who act racist in America are the bad
apples and we should call them out no
matter what their race and it doesn't
implicate the system more broadly the
problem for the left is if you're making
an argument that systems of power are
always implicated by individual events
then you can only show the public
certain events it's very important that
the public only see certain events
because of every incident is just the
tip of the iceberg and the iceberg is
really the problem well then we can only
show you the incidents that back our
narrative and the icebergs that we wish
to talk about so this incident in macy's
of course did not receive the sort of
national news coverage that it would
have received if the races were reversed
neither did that incident in what was it
Michigan where there was a video of a
young black man beating up an elderly
white person neither to that incident in
New York where there was that image of a
young black man walking down the street
he apparently had a bunch of criminal
violations before pushing over a 92 year
old white woman who promptly banged her
head on the sidewalk right none of that
made the news in the same way that the
beatings of Jews and Williamsburg
predominantly by young people of color
did not make the news the reason it
didn't make the news is not because it's
not newsworthy it's because the left
automatically assumes that because they
think of things in terms of race
everybody else will start to it
individual actions to broader races and
then that will back a narrative that
they don't like right and again I'm of
the opinion that you shouldn't
attributes individual instances to
broader narratives without any
supporting evidence but because the left
doesn't routinely they're afraid of this
is how you end up with censorship the
way you end up with censorship is
because there are people on the Left who
believe that every individual incident
is indicative of a broader system of
power and so we can only show you
certain incidents that back our notions
of which power ought to govern and which
power ought not govern but this is part
of the broader point which is that and
by the way that is a that is a status
quo that is sort of accepted by most
Americans most Americans are not
clamoring to see more of this macy's
incident on TV and the reason is because
most americans are uncomfortable with
with racist incidents and uncomfortable
with racism more generally Americans are
trying to wipe racism away it is
something they wish to do and you're
seeing that it's pretty incredible
you're seeing this on a wide variety of
levels the attempt to bend over
backwards to wipe away non racism over
and over so 30 rock is now pulling
certain episodes from syndication
because supposedly characters in the in
the show appeared in blackface and I
don't actually remember those episodes I
remember watching 30 rock it didn't III
don't remember the episodes off the top
of my head but Tina Fey put out a notice
she said as we strive to do the work and
do better in regards to race in America
we believe that these episodes featuring
actors in race changing makeup our best
taken out of circulation I understand
now that intent is not a free pass for
white power for white people to use
these images I apologize for the pain
they have caused going forward no comedy
loving kid needs to stumble on these
tropes and be stunned by their ugliness
I thank NBC Universal for honoring this
request of 30 rock pulled down some
episodes there were two episodes in
question moments was episode 2 of season
3 and one was episode 10 of season 5
both of them featured Jane Krakowski
character Jenna in blackface I believe
that the idea here was to parody
blackface if I recall this correctly the
whole thing was to make fun of racism
I'm fairly certain that Tina Fey and the
folks over at NBC we're not like oh
let's do let's do old-fashioned
blackface and make fun of black people
pretty sure that's not the case but even
making fun of blackface is no longer
acceptable by the way we know that
acceptable because the Washington Post
around a 3,000 were piece castigating
one of its own former staffers who's
like an
internet person for having the temerity
to mop megyn kelly by dressing up as
megyn kelly in blackface
after that entire silly scandal a few
years back he's speaking of people who
are now being targeted for not being
woken up see here's the thing once you
buy into the narrative that America is
broadly speaking racist despite all
proof to the contrary there is no end to
it once you once you buy into the idea
that you don't have to spot individual
instances of racism all you have to
identify is inequality of outcome well
then there is no end to this routine and
the people who will find themselves on
the chopping block first are the people
who are most likely to cave so this is
why Bill Simmons finds himself on the
chopping block today so what did Bill
Simmons do wrong right the sports guy
it's in the near attempts as a long
piece today called sports media giant
Bill Simmons finds himself playing
defense what did he do did he say the
n-word did he mistreat a black person no
no he didn't what did he do well on June
1st there was an episode of Bill Simmons
his podcast called a truly sad week in
America in which Simmons talked about
the black lives matter movement with a
frequent guest the ringer podcaster Ryan
rasilla lucilla was one of the founding
editors of the site and a good friend of
Simmons Andrew silho spoke of what he
described as looters who were breaking
into sneaker shops which is a thing that
happened okay you know how I know that
happened to happen two blocks from my
house literally in the middle of the in
the middle of the the unrest in Los
Angeles there's a footlocker like three
blocks away and people broke into the
footlocker I mean the good news was that
they broke a window and somebody got
caught they called an ambulance the guy
was fine not kidding that that's an
actual thing that happened but roof sill
Oh made a big mistake during the podcast
lucilla complimented Simmons on his
hiring practices praising his boss for
quote the jobs and opportunities he'd
given a diverse group then Simmons and
Wasilla were forced to apologize because
it set off a social media backlash and
was described as preposterous in the New
York Daily News the ringer Union
affiliated with the Writers Guild of
America represents about 65 employees
the outlet has no black editors or staff
writers covering the NBA or NFL so hold
on I have a question does that mean no
black people work at the ringer no it
doesn't it just means they're not in
certain positions at the ringer but then
Simmons had to prostrate himself before
the woke gods of the New York Times he
said in an email to the New York Times
that the ringer fell short on diversity
and that he expects to make personnel
announcements soon that will show
that the company is making progress on
the issue and then held an All Hands
meeting a few days after the podcast
episode Simmons told the staff who's
going to make mistakes but that you
tried to learn from them by the way I
believe that they have two separate
podcast hoes who are black at least
right Jamel hello I believe hosted a
podcast with the ringer and so does
Larry Wilmore is my understanding host
of podcast with the ringer so the idea
that this is like a black free company
or something
well that bill Simmons a vicious racist
is plainly ridiculous it's plainly
ridiculous but now he is on the chopping
block because apparently he has not
hired enough black folks the bringer has
six black editorial staff members at
about 90 employees according to the
Union three of them are writers a fourth
black writer was hired to cover the NFL
starting in July between 2017 and 2019
at least five black editorial staff
members left the company so that means
presumably that he had more black
staffers and some of them left but the
New York Times quoted these four former
black employees three of whom spoke on
condition of anonymity for fear of
antagonizing Simmons and they said they
often felt uncomfortable at the ringer a
few of that why were they uncomfortable
a few of them said they were sometimes
heaped with racist abused on social
media and in online comments when they
heard when they covered topics that
might not have fit the expectations of
the typical ringer reader including a
post on Beyonce and top editors didn't
go on social media and defend them so
it's not that the the ringer did
something bad to their own employees as
they posted articles and people were
mean to them online and gave them the
SADS and their editors didn't come out
of the woodwork to defend them from the
the cruelty of the comment section first
of all if you work in the Internet first
rule of working on the internet guys
never read the comments never read the
comments but just like every other woke
company the wringer is now being
basically held hostage in his staffing
decisions by woke staffers who have
decided that they are going to hold
accountable the editorial structure that
pays them for decisions that they don't
actually get to make the point here is a
is a more general one which is it seems
to me there's a pretty widespread
attempt happening right now to fight
racism know it seems like Americans
broadly speaking are pretty and like
they're saying what do you want from us
what what do you need what what do you
mean what do you want us to do what do
you want us to do and the answer is all
the things the answer is the woke left
ones all the things every single thing
there are no things that the woke left
does not want we're going to get to that
in just one second
first let us talk about the fact a lot
of people right now asking themselves
can I still get life insurance I mean
there's a pandemic on can I get a life
insurance the answer is you can you can
indeed you can buy life insurance during
a pandemic if you have loved ones
depending on your income you probably
should
as an insurance marketplace policy
genius is in contact with the life
insurance companies on their platform
every day they are keeping track of all
the changes in the market so you don't
have to that means they can get you
covered quickly and for the best price
here's how it works
policy genius will compare quotes from
the top life insurance companies all in
one place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price that doesn't just
save a lot of legwork it could save
fifteen hundred bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free so
if you hit any speed bumps during that
application process they will be there
to take care of everything so if you're
one of many people looking to buy life
insurance right now but you're not sure
exactly where to start head on over to
policy genius.com policy genius will
help you find the best rate handle the
process completely go get you and your
family protected hopefully give you one
less thing to worry about that's policy
genius.com go there for all of your
insurance needs get that taken care of
be a responsible human policy genius.com
okay so what exactly does the woke left
want the answer is the woke left wants
all of the things so Shaun King of the
New York Daily News and a
self-proclaimed civil rights leader he
reacted to a post from match lab match
lab as the head of the American and
Conservative Union and a match lab had
tweeted out that sooner or later the
left was going to come for statues of
Jesus they're coming for statues of
literally everyone else and Shaun King
immediately tweeted back yes I think the
statues of the white European they claim
is Jesus should also come down they are
a form of white supremacy
always have been in the Bible when the
family of Jesus wanted to hide and blend
in guess where they went
Egypt not Denmark tear them down so
tears down every depiction of Jesus as a
white person by the way Jesus was not
black person either Jesus was a Jew okay
probably look like my father-in-law
Bhaiji seriously you look like a
modern-day Israeli probably Jesus he's
probably a short stubby Jew right that's
it because guess what that's what like
he was a Jew I don't want to tell you
about this right he probably did not
look like a six-foot-five nor Norwegian
right let's I I get it but the idea that
you were going to tear down all art of
Jesus then he continued along these
he said yes all murals and stained glass
windows white cheeses and his European
mother and their white friends should
also come down there a gross form of
white supremacy created as tools of
oppression racist propaganda they should
all come down so how do you feel about
shattering all the stained glass windows
what do you think should we just go -
you know all of the world's historic
churches and start shattering windows
apparently the answer is yes okay and
the any attempt to tear down statues
continued apace it's all statues is all
statutes right it is not just restricted
to Confederate monuments is not just
restricted to hit two people in history
who have very checkered past the end of
jak sins of the world they tried to tear
that statue down in Lafayette Park last
night it's not just restricted to Old
Confederate right Teddy Roosevelt
statues need to be taken down Bill de
Blasio has had the Teddy Roosevelt did
things that are deeply disturbing we're
five seconds away by the way from the
blow up Mount Rushmore movements like
that that is five seconds away because
Mount Rushmore features a bevy of people
who have all been canceled in fact
there's nobody on Mount Rushmore who has
not been canceled all right all the
people in Mount Rushmore at this point
have been canceled so far as I am aware
right George Washington has had his
statues torn down and so has Thomas
Jefferson Abraham Lincoln has been
canceled by people who have suggested
that you know if you look at his early
writings he talked about taking black
people and creating Liberia and moving
them back to Africa and he wasn't in
favor of racial of racial equality he
wasn't even in favor of getting rid of
slavery at the outset of the Civil War
so Abraham Lincoln has been cancelled
and now Teddy Roosevelt is being
cancelled here's Bill DeBlasio giant
weirdo and groundhog murderer talking
about how Teddy Roosevelt is canceled
Roosevelt himself is a another one of
these complex figures in American
history he did some extraordinarily
progressive things that we feel to this
day and he did some things that I think
are deeply troubling but I think there's
a separate question between him the
person and the actual statue the statue
has representations that clearly do not
represent today's values the statue
clearly you know presents a white man as
superior to people of color okay that is
not really what the statute was
dedicated to do but in any case Bill
DeBlasio and the rest of the of the new
communist crew have figured out exactly
what
that they want and what they want is all
of the things all of the things and this
does tie into a broader narrative again
of American racism and American evil Tom
cotton senator from Arkansas he pointed
out yesterday when you ripped down
Washington and grant you're not doing
that because you want to correct
American history you're doing that
because you really don't like the
country and you think the country from
inception is evil and bad you're talking
not just about ripping down monuments of
Confederates who fought against the
Union you're talking about ripping down
the Union itself witness the events of
just this past weekend where mobs tore
down statues of George Washington and
ulysses s grant when you tear down
statues of Washington and Grant it's not
about the Civil War it's because you
hate America and indeed these rioters
hate America in Portland where they tore
down the statue of Washington they also
spray-painted on him the date 16:19
a reference to the New York Times's
revisionist anti American history
project okay he's exactly right about
all this and this is part of again a
broader goal and the broader goal is
tear down the system the broader goal is
tear down the system now some of the
leaders in the black lives matter
movement will say as much that black
lives matter founder Patrice jewelers
she actually came out a few years back
in 2015 and expressed what exactly her
goals were she said yeah I'm a Marxist
we're friend Marxist like our goal is to
tear down the system I think that the
criticism is helpful I also think that
it might I think of a lot of things the
first thing I think is that we actually
do have an ideological frame myself
analicia in particular trained
organizers we are trained Marxists we
are super versed on sort of ideological
theories it's not about stopping racism
for a lot of the people who are involved
in this
it is about stopping the system itself
because the system itself is supposedly
an outgrowth of racism and bigotry by
the way this is one of the problems that
a lot of people on the Left they don't
understand people on the right and say
well I won't just say black lives matter
okay I'm happy you say black lives
matter
black lives you matter because that's
perfectly obvious it's perfectly obvious
that black lives matter the reason
people object to the phrase black lives
matter is because there's an actual
group called black lives matter and when
people say black lives matter that is a
term that suffers from from in
linguistics they call it semantic
overload is a term that means more than
one thing the group black lives matter
is a Marxist group ok the group itself
which is not the movement right it's
just the group that created the
movements that group is really not a
great group their website specifically
says we call for an end to the systemic
racism that allows this culture of
corruption to go unchecked in our lives
to be taken we need to defund the police
nationally we demand investment in our
communities and the resources to ensure
black people not only survive but thrive
if you're with us add your name to this
petition we disrupt the Western
prescribed a nuclear family structure
required requirement by supporting each
other as extended families and villages
that collectively care for one another
especially our children to the degree
that mothers parents and children aren't
comfortable in other words it's a
Marxist group I mean the BLM website
also takes time out to rip on Israel
because that's what they do
the it's pretty incredible so when
people object to sort of the black lives
matter tag it's because it's not clear
what exactly that means because on the
one hand it's perfectly obvious on the
other it is perfectly not on the one
hand it's perfectly obvious the black
lives matter and everyone a hundred
percent of Americans virtually agrees
with this idea and the ones who don't
are significant outliers that everybody
despises and then you have people who
are the black lives matter organizers
and leaders and members of that group
and the group itself is really not great
and is pushing an agenda that has very
little to do with fighting racism now
coming up in just a second I want to
talk about the generational shift that
is going on because one of the things
that we are watching right now is a
repeat of the 60s when you had an older
generation that had acknowledged its
sins and allowed the younger generation
to run roughshod over them well today
you have the same thing in older
generation that is allowing the younger
generation run roughshod over them the
only difference is that back in the
1960s at least you could make the claim
that the older generation had not done
enough about racism now the older
generation is being run roughshod over
by its children who by and large have
not suffered in a racist America if
you're 20 years old living in the United
States the chances that you suffered
from deep deep personal racism are a lot
lower than they were back in the 1960s
by every available metric idiot their
systems of power that are designed to
keep you down is just not for
in the United States in 2020 it hasn't
been true for quite a while in the
United States was made federally illegal
in the 1960s doesn't mean racism worn
away it doesn't mean that you haven't
experienced any racism in your life it
means the system is not meant to keep
you down and your parents are not the
bad guys are your parents were not
complicit in the system okay but we have
a generational war that it's going on
right now we're gonna get to that in
just one second because there's an
incredible article in The New York Times
talking about this and it does speak to
the I would say dismal future of the
country if young people get their way on
this thing and get to that momentarily
first let us talk about the fact that
sleep is a little bit hard to come by
these days and there's a lot of stress
you're stuck in your house with kids
this is why you need a great mattress to
lie on at night I'm talking about helix
sleep helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper a hot
sleeper whether you like a pusher from
bed with helix there's no more confusion
and no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine and CNN called it the
most comfortable mattress they've ever
slept on just head on over to helix
sleep comm slash men take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress they'll
give you the best sleep of your life
they've got a ten year warranty you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you
absolutely will helix is offering up to
$200 off all mattress orders just for
our listeners get up to 200 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash pen that is helix
sleep comm slash Ben and I love my helix
sleeve mattress my wife and I took that
two minutes sleep quiz and we have a
mattress that is made just for us it is
incredibly comfortable we get great
sleep on it which we definitely need
because we have a newborn go check out
helix sleep right now helix lucam slash
pen get 200 bucks off all mattress
orders just for our listeners helix
sleep comm slash them okay so there's a
generational thing going on here so as
I've talked about on the show before in
the 1960s and I keep quoting Shelby
Steele her because I think that his
insight here is really valuable Shelby
still talks about that in the 1960s
there's a younger generation and they
looked at an older generation that had
been complicit in actual legalized
system of racial discrimination and they
said you don't have any moral legitimacy
anymore and on the basis of that of that
lever
they proceeded to tear down entire
systems everything from sort of
traditional sexual mores to the to the
destruction of educational system right
thing had to go everything had to go
because the idea was our parents have no
moral legitimacy anymore and there was
at least truth to the idea that their
parents generation that the boomers
parents had been complicit in a system
of racism that was particularly true in
the South but was true federally right
that that was true
now fast-forward to 2020 and the kids
are now doing it to their parents so you
have Millennials who are doing it to Gen
Xers and you and you have Gen Xers who
are doing it to the Boomers and the
basic idea here is that the same people
we're ripping on their parents back in
the 60s are now being ripped by their
children for quote-unquote not doing
enough now there's only one problem with
this which is the evidence is pretty
scanty there the onus is really really
scanty it doesn't really exist that the
baby boomers and the Millennials and the
nd Gen Xers that those people are deeply
viciously racist and that evidence just
isn't there and more importantly one of
the things that is happening is when you
attribute to racism the effects of
failures of personal responsibility you
actually end up removing autonomy from
people and when you suggest that the
system is responsible for individual
failings what you end up doing is
creating a discouraging situation for
young people you tell them that all the
problems in your life are not your fault
they are the fault of your parents
generation there are the fault of the
system that is not a recipe for success
it is not it is a recipe for failure one
of the worst things you can do to a
child is tell them that they do not have
the capacity to rise in the freest
country in the history of the world a
country that is diverse and
multicultural and allows opportunities
and equal rights under the law right
that country is a problem and that your
parents just don't get it they don't get
it because you know they made me think
of the old framework where if you remove
the obstacles then you have
opportunities but they need to think of
the new framework wherein anything short
of utopia is evidence of discrimination
this is leading to a younger generation
who have decided that their actual
question life is to tear down the system
that provides them opportunities because
they don't wish to take advantage of the
opportunities themselves there's an
incredible article in The Washington
Post today it's called young Asians and
Latinos push their parents to
acknowledge racism amid protests hey
this is pretty incredible because let's
be frank about this young Asians and
Latinos are experiencing a lot less
racism in the United States than their
parents were
parents did that that is perfectly
obvious they anti-asian sentiments in
the 1980s was much stronger than
anti-asian sentiments in 2020
anti-latino sentiments in the 1970s and
80s much much stronger than anti-latino
sentiments in 2020 perfectly obvious
right by every available veteran but now
you have young people who are pushing
their parents and basically saying that
their parents are racist why because
their parents keep saying things like
individual responsibility their parents
keep saying things like meritocracy
their parents keep teaching them things
like work hard and by doing that they
are complicit in the system according to
the Washington Post the argument began
as soon as Charlie my and his brother
Henry announced their plans to attend a
black lives matter protest that evening
in their seat in DC their father was not
having it Glenn my a retired FBI agent
had been raised in Dallas by Chinese
immigrants who had taught him he would
succeed if he just worked hard Glenn in
54 said quote Chinese culture is very
much about working within the system
during decades in law enforcement he'd
come to believe the system worked his
son Charlie 24 took a different view
my father deeply believes that everyone
has a fair chance which is just
basically untrue said charlie an artist
who fled New York for his family's home
in Northern Virginia because of the
pandemic it's very Asian to me that view
that if everyone just works hard then
everything will turn out alright for
them I'm definitely a little reactive to
that because I think that's delusional
okay I have a question for Charlie
Charlie's an artist in New York had
presumably being subsidized by his
parents his dad who's 54 which means
that he grew up in the 1970s and 1980s
his dad who was 54 who presumably in
Dallas as a Chinese immigrant I mean
that is not exactly a recipe you would
think for never experiencing racial
discrimination says work hard and you'll
get ahead and then he tells his son you
know what happened I worked hard I got
ahead and then his son who's an artist
in New York is like you know what racism
you know what racism is keeping people
down maybe you should listen to your dad
because maybe your dad has more life
experience maybe your dad went through
more crap than you did
maybe it's pretty ungrateful for you to
disparage the country that gave your
father the opportunity that he himself
recognizes he got maybe that's an
absurdity that's you morning amid the
yelling and the tears Glenn threatened
to walk out when it became clear that
Charlie and Henry twenty two plans to
defy the city's 7:00 p.m. curfew in the
end however he drove downtown to bring
his son safely home the argument over
the protest
police brutality and systemic racism has
since softened into an extended
conversation during the civil rights
movement black parents and their
children may have disagreed over speed
and strategy but their shared experience
of discrimination United them on the
cause non black allies many of them
Jewish Americans were clear minority in
the 1960s by contrast the youth led
protests unfolding now in response to
the killing of a black man by a white
Minneapolis police officer are much more
diverse there are a large number of
African Americans who have supported the
BLM movement since its 2014 founding and
many native-born black and white
newcomers whose lives have often
different have often differed
dramatically from their parents but
there's also an unprecedented large
segment of protesters from other
backgrounds some are descended from
immigrants who moved to the United
States generations ago while many others
come from families that have arrived in
great waves since the civil rights
movement spurred passage of the
Immigration and Naturalization Act in
1965 I think what you are seeing is a
decades-long transformation we have
arrived at a real cultural shift said
Jose Antonio Vargas founder of defined
America an immigration advocacy
organization and former Washington Post
reporter of course he's on the far left
in forming a new kind of majority with
black and white protesters Asian and
Latino and other young allies are
fighting are uniting and fighting anti
black racism in many cases are pushing
their mothers and fathers to understand
why change is necessary so basically
parents are being called out by their
children why are they being called out
by their children because they
themselves are saying things like you
know what I came to this country I
worked really hard I got ahead can you
please stop disparaging the country that
gave me that opportunity and their kids
are like you know what no you know no
you're wrong mom and dad I 8 24 year-old
artist living in New York on your
subsidy I have been victimized by
America and America is deeply evil and
racist there's a person named Giselle
Quintero a Washington Post quote sir she
does it upset me to see how unjustly
black people are being treated I have a
platform in this little community so I
knew I had to do something to help out
in early June she posted news on social
media of a protest in front of a mall
near her house her parents Mexican
American business owners and strong
Trump supporters vocally opposed her
plans at first my parents were like this
is stupid all lives matter they didn't
understand the big picture of it that
the system is so messed up nobody
deserves to have a knee on the neck for
eight minutes over a twenty dollar
counterfeit bill Quintero says she grew
up hearing her grandparents tell stories
about how they were prohibited from
drinking and whites only fountains after
long hot days of working in the fields
they just kind of
press those memories and tried to
distinguish themselves by their hard
work and achievement Quintero said and
they're still not being accepted by the
white community okay hold up a second so
your grandparents were segregated at
water fountains and working in the
fields and then took the opportunities
have afforded to them and made an
incredible life for themselves and
you're gonna lecture them on they're
subsumed racism you're going to lecture
them on their on their integration of
white supremacist ideals what have you
gone through young person you've
literally just said that your
grandparents drank and segregated water
fountains and worked in the fields your
great act of heroism is that you once
stood in a parking lot after posting on
Facebook the point here is that many of
the people who are currently protesting
and are going after their parents
they've deemed themselves I mentioned
yesterday a new generation of better
people and here's the thing there's a
new generation of better people I'm not
seeing a lot of evidence is there a new
generation of other people I'm not I'm
not seeing a lot of evidence that
they're doing many worthwhile things
that are making the country a better
place that doesn't mean that again for
the 1,000th time marching hands police
brutality is a bad thing it means that
when you're calling out your parents and
suggesting that your parents are part of
the racist system when they're the ones
who actually went through racism and you
haven't even seen it I'm gonna go no on
that I'm gonna suggest that this is
self-righteousness masquerading as
righteousness on behalf of others and
that there is no actual end goal here
that the end goal here is the self
righteousness that the end goal for many
of the people who are who are claiming
that America is stemming a racist system
is making themselves feel good I have
more proof of this in just one second
there's a Washington Post piece called
is this time different talking about how
there are so many people who support the
black lives matter protest but is this
time different there's not a single
policy prescription in the entire
article because in the end it is all
about what slogans you say to make
yourself feel good for many people for
many many people and you're seeing this
in personal activity by the way I mean
there's their videos emerging they're
just hilarious of white women screaming
at black police officers over systemic
American racism because they read Robyn
DeAngelo's white fragility or something
one of the dumbest books ever written
there's an there I got to show you this
clip there is a clip that there's a clip
of a of a man captain anti-racism
man-bun abusing
police officer to fight racism does
anybody think that that's fighting
racism or is it possible that this is a
lot of people many of these people
particularly the white woke liberals who
are making themselves feel really good
on the back of no actual agenda because
this is all about a primal cry of I
matter maybe I haven't accomplished
anything but I matter and I know better
than my parents and my parents may have
accomplished something but you know what
I matter because I posted a square on
Facebook that's that's what truly
matters here that is not making the
world a better place but I think that
for many of the the particularly white
woke folks this is not about making the
world a better place it's about
relieving the the feelings of
inferiority they have about their own
lives and then trying to and then trying
to suggest that their parents are the
bad guys in this particular scenario I'm
get some more of this in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
now is a terrible time to go to the auto
parts store I mean frankly it's never a
great time go to the auto parts stores a
good shot you're gonna be overcharged
there's a very good shot they don't have
the right part that they have the
generic part where they have to order it
in why not just go to rockauto.com and
use the interwebs to find the exact part
that you need rockauto.com always offers
the lowest price as possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do I spent up to
twice as much for the same exact parts
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts the wroclaw TOCOM catalog is
unique remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
that amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need check them out over at Rock Auto
calm head on over to Rock auto come
right now see all the parts available
for your
car or truck Android Shapiro in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you again that's Rock
Auto calm you use the Internet to save
yourself time and money and get the
exact part that you need rockauto.com
again that is rockauto.com and then
how'd you hear about us box
make sure the right Shapiro so they know
that we sent you alrighty we're gonna
get into more of this more of the virtue
signaling at the expense of your parents
actually went through stuff and we're
involved in actual change like the lack
of respect for elders here is truly
astonishing it's truly an amazing
amazing thing and the broadening of the
agenda out from you know police
brutality is bad to everything to tear
down stained glass windows of white
Jesus and tear down every statue you can
find and this is all justified because
it's year zero that's it that smacks of
nothing so much as a bored population
assuming that the that the sort of
natural state of things is stasis in
peace and as we're about to find out
that is absolutely not the natural state
of things well get to that in a moment
first if you're not already a daily
where remember you should consider
getting a readers pass today Lee Weyer
calm it is a great value for only three
bucks a month and when you sign up get
that first month for only 99 cents you
also get access to our mobile app
articles had free access to exclusive
editorials like the one that we put up
yesterday six heroic members of law
enforcement that deserve praise and
recognition remember there are good
members of law enforcement remember that
so if you haven't checked out the
readers pass already go to daily
wire.com sign up for just a buck also my
new book is out July 21st how to destroy
America in three easy steps it is all
the things it is all the things we are
watching it take place in real time I'm
not saying I'm a prophet all I'm saying
is that this book which was written back
in December and January it literally
could not be more relevant the basic
premise of the book is that there's a
group of people I call them the
disintegration is in America or seeking
to destroy American history hey the
16:19 project comes on comes in for some
criticism there's seem to destroy
American history they're seeking to
destroy American philosophy the idea of
equal rights before the law and they're
seeking to destroy our culture of rights
suggesting that rights like free speech
are a threat to people of color are a
threat to minorities in the United
States it's really ugly it's really bad
my book isn't just a critique of the
disintegration its position it debunked
a lot of their arguments it's a very
very useful tool for you and not only
discerning what exactly is going on but
in fighting back against the insanity
that we are currently seeing again it's
called how to destroy America in three
easy steps I think it's really deeply
important go pre order today at
we're calm and /ban that his daily wire
comment / ben you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so what will it all add up to
right supposedly we're in a chain a time
of change right this momentous change
time have you seen a lot of talk about
policy have you there was a police
reform bill that was a that was put
forward by Republicans it's basically
stalled for the moment maybe it'll pass
maybe it won't does anyone think that
that's gonna satisfy anybody instead
what we've decided is that we are in a
perpetual Cultural Revolution a
perpetual Cultural Revolution and that's
the only thing that matters the only
thing that matters is the canceled
culture the actual legislation doesn't
matter because guess what discrimination
has been illegal in the United States in
employment and housing has been illegal
for decades in the United States
federally ok but the idea here is that
we have reached a new moment now the
media never to find what the new moment
is and herein lies the key there is no
end goal here there is no end goal the
only end goal is the perpetual
attempt to get people to a tonne of sins
they did not commit and to blame the
country and their parents for all of the
problems that they experienced in their
lives you know the only successful
societies ever built and the only
successful people who have ever lived
are people who believe they have their
own agency people who believe they have
agency in their own lives and have the
capacity to act within their own lives
successfully we are forthwith building a
society that is pushing the notion
extraordinarily hard that you have no
agency that all the things in your life
are built upon systems and those systems
deprive you of agency so you are never
responsible for your own decisions case
in point article in New York Times white
Americans say they are waking up to
racism
what will it add up to one recent
afternoon while washing his car
Gregory's a white stay-at-home dad in
Campton Kentucky peeled off a
confederate flag magnet he'd placed on
its trunk six years earlier he did not
put it back on was a small act for which
he expected no accolades it should not
have taken the police killing of George
Floyd mr. Reese new to face what he had
long known to be true that the flag had
grown up thinking of as a beautiful
trophy was a symbol of hate and it's
obviously wrong to glorify it so number
one I have a question and says it was a
small act for which he expected no
accolades why is it leaving a piece in
the new york times how did how did that
end up in the new york times you expect
no accolades for it but you're talking
to the New York Times about it seems
kind of like you expect a few accolades
this is stay now cried over mr. Floyd's
death has compelled many white Americans
to acknowledge the anti black racism
that is prevalent in the United States
and to perhaps even
salmon their own culpability for it it
is that though the ability of white
people to collectively ignore the
everyday experience of black people has
been short-circuited at least for now by
the way this is a news article this is
not an opinion article is though the
ability of white people to collectively
ignore the everyday experience of black
people has been short-circuited at least
for now so the assumptions that are
baked into this cake which is that all
black people experience the same racism
in the United States that all black
people are ground under the Bootheel of
America's systemic evils like that is
the premise of the article large numbers
of white Americans have attended racial
justice demonstrations purchased books
about racial inequality and register for
webinars on how to raise children who
are anti-racist some have asked
themselves pointed question like how
much professional advantage they have
garnered from being white and whether
they would willingly cede it if they
could others are going to tattoo parlors
to cover up images of Confederate flags
swastikas and Ku Klux Klan symbols on
their bodies okay a question like what
are the percentages here seriously like
how many people had the KKK symbol on
their body and didn't know it was racist
I feel like that I feel like that one
you probably should have known guys you
probably should have known the New York
Times says it's hard to know how deep or
why these responses run and whether they
are the result of pressure from peers
and to appear tolerant or if meaningful
action will follow anti-racism activist
have specified concerns that are not
only about symbols or slurs but entire
governing systems about how Americans
live okay and then it doesn't suggest
anything that Americans can actually do
to fix these systems
nothing like literally nothing the
entire article is just about how white
people are now recognizing that America
is bad and that's the first step to
change that's the first step to change
is recognizing that America is bad and
then recognizing your own culpability in
the badness of America that's really
what this is about now the problem is
that once you start down that process
there is no there's no end to the
process because America is not utopia it
never will be
because utopia doesn't exist and in fact
the places where we are attempting to
establish utopia are falling apart
pretty quickly so the chazz zone in
Seattle Chas shop is coming to an
inglorious end remember mayor Jenny
gherkin remember her she was the one who
suggested that it was basically an
outdoor Street Fair and that she was
just gonna allow it to happen it was all
good times over there until a couple
people got shot a couple nights ago and
the cops couldn't get in because
protesters were blocking in the cops
from getting in well now Seattle mayor
Jenny Durkin said that the Seattle
Police Department will be returning to
its abandoned his precinct building
peacefully and in the near future
following a weekend in which three
people were shot at the edges of the
protest area that has emerged around the
building Durkin said the city would
attempt to phase down nighttime activity
in the Capitol Hill organized protest
area known as chop or earlier as Chas
but would not be using police to clear
the zone rather said Durkin they'd be
asking people to leave the area
voluntarily at night offering resources
for homeless people and working with
community groups to try to cajole people
to leave the area where dozens of tens
have sprouted up in recent weeks along
with couches gorilla gardens and
graffiti gorillas like gue RR I ll a
gorilla gardens and graffiti Durkin said
it's time for people to go home it's
time for us to restore at Cal Anderson
and Capitol Hill so it can be a vibrant
part of our commute but I thought it was
a vibrant part of the community I was
informed that this one time is for
public's autonomous zone was a full
flowering of American democracy jay
Inslee literally said the Trump hates
democracy for saying that he didn't like
Chaz and that it was a separate
historian ization inside a major
American city Sirkin said the impacts on
the businesses and residents in the
community are now too much oh now they
are oh I see now she just expects that
she's gonna be able to send over a few
people to be like you know guys if you
could clear this that'd be really great
they've built up barricades there so I'm
really looking forward to seeing how
exactly the Chaz chop comes to an end
see one of the great lies about where we
are in American history is this belief
that this is the norm that the great
peace and prosperity we've experienced
as a people over the last several
decades now that is the norm in human
life and that you can rip down all of
the systems and maintain the norm you
can rip down equal rights before law and
maintain the norm but you can change the
definition of racism from actual racism
to the systems of oppression are
preventing people from expressing
themselves fully and all failures of
personal responsibility are attributable
to the system you can redefine racism as
that and that that won't have any impact
on the systems in which we live you can
tear down the systems and keep all the
good stuff in other words they can just
tear away the roots of a building and
then expect that the building is going
to stand on air that's not the way any
of this works it ends up more like Chaz
chopped it ends up more like separate
black and white zones which is by the
way something that white protesters were
creating inside Chaz shop there's video
of them separating people out because
they want to make safe spaces for black
people which is also called segregation
okay that that is a bad thing typically
in the United States you separate people
on the basis of race even the left
recognize
that in practical terms what they're
calling for is not a thing that is
practical which is exactly why the DC
police refused to allow the setting up
of a black black house autonomous zone
outside the White House and the DC
police by the way stopped the the
tearing down of an Andrew Jackson statue
in Lafayette Park on Monday night also
the members of the black house
autonomous zone decided that they were
going to spray-paint Saint John's Church
again so that's great there's been like
a couple of pictures of that president
Trump appears outside there it's a big
picture they tried to burn it down and
they spray-paint it approached the
protesters slash riders and and that's
totally fine totally no big deal by the
way question is is the mayor Mayor
Bowser
over over in DC is she a racist now
because she's shutting down the Black
House autonomous zone I've been reliably
informed that if you're a member of a
system of power and you do not allow
these sorts of flowerings of democracy
to occur that you are part of the racist
problem in America today as the agenda
gets vaguer and vaguer the actual agenda
gets clearer and clearer as it turns out
that there is no policy agenda that in
reality what we are watching more and
more is the is a movement dedicated to
the destruction of American principles
more wholly not just fighting racist
incidents and not just and not just
fighting police brutality but something
broader all right something completely
disconnected from any policy then we
were watching is actually just a
cultural revolution not not an actual
legislative attempt it becomes obvious
that that's not something that America
can go along with and be okay with if
you're trying to tear down America from
the root and expect the structure to
stand then you are sadly mistaken the
structure will not stand the structure
will not stand already well we've
reached the end of today's program but
we'll be back here tomorrow
sorry quick note I want to add a quick
thing that I like so quick thing and I
like here there's a very good book by a
guy named Wesley yang he's written for
The New Yorker he is not on the right
eye has a book called the essay called
the souls of yellow folk obviously named
after the book the souls of black folk I
and and the book of essays is really
interesting it's about Asian Americans
in the United States and how they have
dealt with discrimination in the United
States is a couple of incredible essays
near the end of the book about the
changing phraseology the change
phraseology from white supremacy to
whiteness being the problem the change
of phraseology from racism to systems of
oppression here's a couple of essays in
this book that are really worth reading
you should really check it out book
again is called the the souls of yellow
folk by Wesley yang so go check that out
we will be back here tomorrow with much
more content on the podcast otherwise
we'll see you here later today for two
additional hours of content plus I
believe I have an all-access live
tonight so check out daily where I can
become a subscriber you can hang out
with me I'll wear a t-shirt we can ask
questions that's pretty much the pitch
so go enjoy that over daily we're calm
you're listening to the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel white house key technical
producer Austin Stevens playback in
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike foramina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to Andrew Kleber
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]